Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and there’s
a whole lot of Walking Dead stuff going on
right now so I’ll try to cover it all in
this video.
First AMC just officially ordered a pilot
for the Spinoff TV Series.
So I’ll do a big update on what’s going
on with that.
I know a lot of you want to know what it’s
about and some are wondering why they’re
even making a spinoff.
And Norman Reedus posted a potentially spoilery
Daryl image to facebook yesterday.
So after spinoff talk I’ll explain what
that was all about.
Hint, it might not be a spoiler.
Especially if he posted it to his mega facebook
page.
So don’t freak out yet.
If you’re just finding me for the first
time I’m doing weekly walking dead videos
for season 5 and just like last year I’ll
also be doing a weekly giveaway.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Now, important stuff first.
WTF is the spinoff all about and why haven’t
they been talking about it more?
The Spinoff is going to be a completely different
group of characters not in or around the places
featured on the main tv show right now.
So no Georgia, no Washington, no Terminus.
Somewhere else presumably in America.
It’s possible they could choose to shoot
it in Vancouver to save money on production,
but for all intents and purposes the story
will still be based in the United States.
The idea of a Walking Dead show taking place
in Europe or China would be cool, but those
types of shows usually happen when Studios
sell the rights in other countries.
For instance, Breaking Bad sold the rights
to the show in Mexico, so there’s a hispanic
version of Breaking Bad with it’s own set
of characters.
The story is pretty much the same but the
show is called Metastasis and instead of being
Walter White, the main character is Walter
Blanco.
It’s Breaking Bad produced in spanish instead
of being subtitled or dubbed.
So if you want to see what’s happening in
south america right now
in the walking dead universe.
That would probably be how it would happen.
Right now the spinoff has just been greenlit
for a pilot.
Meaning AMC will pay 4 or 5 million dollars
for them to produce a one or two hour pilot
episode.
AMC will then either decide to order it to
series or they’ll pass on it and try for
another spinoff in a couple years.
There have been a lot of rumors about when
the story would take place.
The biggest theory is that it would cover
the time leading up to the virus outbreak.
I don’t think that’s true but it’s one
of the better theories.
It’s more likely that Robert Kirkman, who’s
working on the pilot himself, will try to
capitalize on the aspects of the Walking Dead
Universe that people love the most.
And Walking Dead is all about people trying
to survive in the fallout.
Making a show about an impending viral outbreak
would be more like a procedural.
It would be more like World War Z, with everyone
dealing with the outbreak.
When I think it’s so much more interesting
to see the aftermath.
If you look at the Walking Dead Telltale game,
it’s got an amazing narrative with a completely
different group of characters taking place
concurrently with events in the comic book.
I think the spinoff will do a similar thing.
I think the success of the telltale game gives
Robert Kirkman a lot of confidence that a
completely different story set during the
same time period is still something people
want.
Here’s a big question for you guys, let
me know in the comments.
If it had to take place in the United States.
Where would you want the spinoff to take place,
in a big city or in another rural area like
Macon Georgia where Terminus is supposed to
be?
Or do you totally not care where it is?
There’s this really weird thing I’ve noticed
with the fandom.
Right now Walking Dead is the most popular
show on cable, by a wide margin.
It’s more popular than Game of Thrones because
Game of Thrones is on a premium cable channel.
So fewer people subscribe and have access
to it.
But even though Walking Dead is so popular
and makes crazy dump trucks of money.
I see it get a lot of hate from some of the
core audience.
Like people in general love it, but there’s
a large group of people that also really hate
it.
Let me know where you fall on the spectrum.
Personally I’ve already bought my ticket
and I’ll ride the train all the way to Hogwarts
or Terminus depending on where you think the
show will end.
I’m of the opinion that when it does end
it will be more ambiguous, like a few of the
characters will just trudge on into the distance
and try to keep surviving.
I don’t think they’ll ever cure the virus.
That’s not what the show is about.
It’s about surviving to the last breath.
Surviving with machine guns.
But eventually you have to run out of bullets,
this isn’t a Rambo movie where you have
unlimited ammo.
Speaking of unlimited ammo, Daryl and his
crossbow were spotted on set.
Norman Reedus posted a picture that teases
something from the comics but really I think
it’s a misdirect.
I don’t think he’d ever do something so
stupid as to spoil a big reveal.
I’m going to talk more about Daryl in general,
but for a couple of these images I’ll say
potential spoiler warning.
I’ll leave this hashtag up for the duration.
Everybody ready...okay, here we go.
So Norman Reedus posted a couple images with
greg nicotero on set.
He has a bloodied hand in one of them and
in another picture, there’s a hand on the
ground with the caption “Divorced”.
Notice the wedding ring on his hand.
The hand in the first picture, this one.
Is a different hand than the one on the ground
here.
So clearly he’s messing with us.
The whole thing had people nuts because it’s
a twist on another big character in the comics
getting their hand chopped off.
Just to answer the biggest question.
No I do not think Daryl will get his hand
chopped off, I don’t remember him even wearing
a wedding ring.
And they’re not going to maim one of the
main characters unless they intend to kill
them off.
Hershel’s leg made sense because that character
isn’t the crazy action based fighting person
Rick or Daryl or Abraham are.
Season 5 is all about action.
So yes, someone will get their hand chopped
off, but I don’t think it will be Rick or
Daryl.
What I do think will happen is some random
person will get a hand chopped off and it
will be the show’s way of winking at the
comic books without having to go through the
burden of writing around a missing hand for
the next 3 or 4 seasons.
Spoilers over.
There was a shot in the trailer of Carl with
an eye patch, which mirrors something from
the comics, but I don’t think any of the
bigger lead characters will suffer crazy maiming
injuries.
There have been lots of rumors about one of
them dying, but at this point, the show has
diverged so much from the comics, I try to
not make huge comic predictions.
Norman Reedus spent a lot of time talking
about Season 5 Daryl.
And for me at least in season 4, he was one
of the more interesting people on the show.
He said that he’s going to be much more
feral this year.
As in feral cat, with a large weapon.
It’s really interesting to see how his character
has changed from season 1 to now.
I feel like Rick has re-taken the leadership
role but it almost felt like farmer rick meant
Daryl was going to step up and be the new
prison leader.
Even though technically they had the council.
When we first met him and Meryl in season
1 he was so much more of an outsider.
That whole beth two part episode filled in
a lot of his childhood too.
He had a pretty shitty upbringing, an like
a lot of children of abuse, he didn’t turn
into the happiest most social of creatures.
In a way, the apocalypse has been really good
to him.
In order to survive he’s had to learn to
be around and trust people.
He still shrugs his way through conversations,
but I really do think he feels like Rick’s
brother.
I think he totally believed it when he and
Rick were talking the morning after the big
WTF Claimers scene.
Rick hasn’t replaced Meryl, but Daryl is
just open to the idea of the survivors as
his family and friends.
He’s not the Navel gazing grumpy person
from season 1, I think watching him learn
to become a normal human has been half the
fun of the character.
The Crossbow really does it for me too.
The crossbow is where a lot of the fun is.
Season 5 is obviously a bit of a dog fight
in terms of the first half of the season.
I had thought they’d wait till season 6
to do the Road to Washington DC, but it seems
like based on production images, shit will
go down at Terminus very very fast.
So Daryl’s arc in season 5 isn’t going
to be so much about integrating with the group,
it will be more like Rick’s.
A lot of ass kicking for about 8 episodes.
I think when he lost Beth he kind of stalled
out emotionally, had she not been taken he
probably would have continued to open up.
Maybe smiled a lot more.
But remember what he looked like when the
Claimers found him.
He was just slumped down in the middle of
the road in a pile of fail.
It was like he regressed completely.
The whole shit show at terminus is going to
jump start him in a big way.
Like Norman Reedus said, you stick him in
a train car, he’s going to turn in to a
feral cat.
What happens when you open the door.
He jumps out claws first.
The thing I’m most looking forward to from
Daryl in Season 5 is the reunion with Beth.
Which probably won’t happen for a long time.
I feel like once he finds beth again he’ll
get some closure on season 4 and he’ll be
able to start becoming a better human being
again.
But let me know in the comments, what are
you most excited to see Daryl do in season
5.
Besides kill a lot of people with the crossbow?
I probably won’t do a Q&A video for this
just because of Korra and Doctor Who this
weekend, but now that we’re getting closer
to the premiere I’m going to start doing
more bonus videos.
So feel free to leave me suggestions for things
you guys want to talk about.
My next bonus video will probably post next
Friday and I’ll probably do another character
video be sure to subscribe to get it, maybe
for Carl or Rick or maybe Michonne.
I’ll get to them all eventually.
right now click here for my breakdown of the
season 5 trailer and click here to learn about
some of the new characters this season.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!